Welcome back everyone
Marvel just revealed who the real main
villain of Deadpool 3 is going to be.
And it's a huge deep
cut for the X-Men movies
and for the previous Deadpool movies.
We knew there'd be a bunch of comic book
accurate
versions of the X-Men
showing up in the movie
with all the classic X-Men coming back.
So no big surprise that the actual main
villain of the movie will be a big twist
on a familiar character,
like one of those classic X-Men
coming back in
from the recent Marvel movies
to like building
on the plot of the recent Marvel movies.
Mild shock.
you're brand new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos.
And speaking of big crossover
with Deadpool three.
Loki Season two
episodes are coming in a couple of months
that will cross over with Deadpool
three in a much bigger way.
Like literally because of all the TVA
characters that are in Deadpool three.
But the big news you may have seen is
the actual main villain is a super deep
cut for the more recent X-Men comics.
In a dark twist on Professor X,
who will come back at some point
during the movie
in a very twisty kind of way.
Patrick Stewart's Professor
X isn't meant to be the main villain.
Deadpool is supposed to travel
to the A38 universe at some point.
Scarlet Witch killed
most of the Illuminati, including him
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
reportedly Patrick Stewart is featured
at some point during the movie,
so Deadpool might visit the E3 universe
before the events of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
But I think they're supposed to deal
with the aftermath of what Scarlet Witch
did, killing most of the team.
it sounds like they'll just explain him
appearing in the movie in some flashback
kind of way.
Or Deadpool just appears
in a couple of different parts
of the timeline in the A3 universe.
they're couple easy time travel ways
to explain how he shows up in the movie.
But he's still dead in present day.
and we already knew that
Emma Corrin was playing the main villain.
But the early report is that she'd be
a TVA judge, kind of like Wren Slayer.
Now it seems like she's actually playing
Cassandra Nova,
who is the evil twin of Professor X.
That's the super deep cut for the X-Men
comics and for the recent Deadpool movies.
during Deadpool two?
One of the main villains was Juggernaut
Professor X's brother.
So it's just like another member
of Professor X's family, Cassandra
Nova has a really crazy backstory,
so I'll explain her.
she's a relatively newer character
from the recent new X-Men
run in the early 2000.
That was Grant Morrison's run.
So no surprise.
Deadpool one,
to borrow from one of the comic book
Masters, is a great run
if you haven't read it.
they even borrowed a little bit
from that run for X-Men Dark Phenix.
the costumes
that the X-Men team is wearing during
that are from that new X-Men run.
Her full name, though, is Cassandra Nova.
Xavier because Charles Xavier
in as you would expect
from Grant Morrison,
her backstory is totally nuts.
like, how did Professor X have a twin
that we just learned about in the twins?
He explained that
because Professor X was born so powerful,
his genetic potential was so great
when he was in his mother's womb growing,
it caused the creation of a fraternal
twin to form from the living embodiment
of Professor X's antiseptic,
this cosmic form that took shape
because he was so powerful.
they explain that the
she r have this concept
saying that each person has an opposite
or an anti form of themselves that exist
cosmically out there in the universe,
but usually just this formless
cosmic energy that never takes shape,
especially for people who aren't
that powerful like normal humans.
But because Professor X was so powerful
even in his mother's womb,
his antics Self was able to take
for sort of like latch on to him
and use that to take form
and become his fraternal twin.
later
taking the name Cassandra Nova Xavier.
And because they're fraternal twins
in the comics, he looks exactly like him.
Just female, now.
Emma Corrin doesn't look anything
like Patrick Stewart, even younger
Patrick Stewart But I think they'll just
kind of wave their hands at that.
Don't worry
that they don't look exactly alike.
They're fraternal twins.
Fraternal twins
look just a tiny bit different.
when they were growing in the womb,
Professor X was so powerful
that he unconsciously became aware of her,
his evil anti self,
and tried to kill her with his mutant
powers like kill his twin in the womb
the event was so crazy
it caused his mother to suffer
a miscarriage
when she gave birth to both them.
And they believe that only Professor
X survived the birth.
But Cassandra Nova,
having powers equal to that of Professor
X was able to survive as a lump of cells
hiding in the walls of the building.
Yes, this is right.
Grant Morrison actually wrote this slowly,
creating a body for herself over decades
until eventually she was able to emerge
looking just like Professor X,
but super evil, super pissed off
and looking for revenge against him.
she became the main villain of that big
Grant Morrison new X-Men run,
and she goes about
trying to destroy the X-Men,
tearing down everything in Professor
X's life, mostly succeeding.
she kills almost everybody
on Juno to the Mutant Island,
then goes after the c r Empire,
and they were only able to stop her
by tricking her
into transferring her consciousness
into a different body,
entrapping her in that form.
weren't able to actually kill her.
Ultimately, they could only contain her
and wipe her memory.
She just came back
in the more recent comics
to working with the Hellfire Club
in the Marauders,
Trying to cause more trouble
for the X-Men.
Professor X was create
more havoc in general.
Eventually, that group, the Marauders
she was working with
tried to trap her in the past too.
Like even the villain she was working with
didn't like her.
soon as of the more recent comics,
she's trapped in the distant past,
still very much alive,
still very much looking for revenge.
supposedly something similar is going on
with her character in Deadpool three.
Like her backstory will be similar to her
comic book origin story.
She was a twin, a Professor X
that he tried to kill in the womb,
but she survived
and has been seeking revenge ever since.
in at least in present
day of the eighth universe,
like after the events of Doctor
Strange Multiverse about as Professor
X being dead means that unless Emma
Frost is in the movie, I don't think
that she is the only telepaths
that they'd have in the A3 universe.
They'd be powerful enough to stop her
would be Jean Gray.
Famke
Janssen is coming back as her character.
she also has her Phenix level powers
and the 838 version
of Scarlet Witch who isn't a telepath
but is super powerful.
Hopefully the movie will not end
with a more comic book
accurate version of Wolverine.
Just trying to repeat the ending
from X-Men
Last Stand This time, instead of him
trying to stop the Phenix from going crazy
and killing everyone, it's
an evil version of Professor X
let me know in the comments.
What do you think about them using
Cassandra Nova, Professor X's evil twin
as the main villain of the movie?
I definitely like that they're not just
going back to a version of Scarlet Witch
being the main villain or some old tropes
from previous X-Men movies.
We already know that Mobius Miss Minutes.
Some of the TVA will be
a big part of Deadpool three,
but they're also introducing a couple of
new TVA characters during Deadpool three.
Matthew McFayden from Succession
is playing a TVA agent named Paradox,
who Mobius assigns
to Deadpool in Wolverine's case
and just tasks him with dealing with them
through the movie.
Miss Minutes
will probably just be around the TVA.
Snarking with Deadpool.
But. For example,
if you look at their fight here
as it goes
on, they're crashing through the Fox logo.
You notice Wolverine
picking up the severed pieces of Deadpool
Loki literally picks up Deadpool's arm
and throws it at Deadpool so hard that he
crashes through the back of the Fox logo
this is going to be so crazy and so meta.
I love it.
literally and metaphorically
killing the Fox Marvel universe
Pretty much everybody been
joking about this for years.
Like, wouldn't it be awesome
if they did a Deadpool movie?
Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe,
but they'll never do something like that.
Is too crazy touch a few years later
and Ryan Reynolds is like,
Oh yeah, we're doing it.
We're totally doing it
now we know why they released the official
HD Shiny Copy that Wolverine first
look earlier this year of him
in the yellow suit from the comics.
It's because that we're going
to be filming all these scenes outdoors
and everybody got videos
of the entire fight scene.
they have about two months of filming
left on the movie, which is a lot.
And they pause because the actors strike.
They just started. So
eventually they will just pick up again.
Reportedly before they had to stop.
They also filmed a bunch of indoor scenes
inside the TVA,
probably right before they get pruned
and sent to the void here.
My guess is that just based on
what happened during the Loki series,
when all beings typically get pruned,
they're given the choice to either
become TB agents because all the TB agents
are variants themselves.
that wound up having to Loki
during Loki season one, like he chose
to become a tbia agent
or they get pruned outright.
Like you can become an agent
or will prune you
Deadpool Wolverine probably do something
so crazy inside the TBA
when they get arrested
that they get pruned on the spot like they
break out into a fight inside the TVA.
lot of people also asking why they gave
Wolverine sleeves in his yellow suit.
Because normally in the comics,
most of the versions of his suits
don't have sleeves.
This is actually a change they did
because of what happened in real life.
So in real life,
Hugh Jackman just had a skin cancer scare,
so they altered his suit
to give him sleeves so as much of his skin
could be covered while they were filming
outdoors as possible, just for protection.
maybe at some point
the sleeves will get ripped off.
So he'll be more comic book accurate.
The suit does look similar to the one
from X-Men, the Animated series.
But like if you look at the hands
here, like the details, it's actually
based on the one from astonishing X-Men.
the other.
Minor change here, too,
is if you look at a lot of the Fox
Marvel movies, Wolverine's claws came from
between his knuckles
and these are more like the comics
where they come from on top of his hands.
The helmet might wind up either
being a cowl
that's just attached to the suit,
or he might just lose the helmet
earlier in their fight.
Or it could just wind up being CG.
Like a lot of the Iron Man, visual effects
There will be a helmet at some point
during the movie.
the main version of Wolverine here in
the movie is meant to be
from the main house of M Universe
that Deadpool travels to in the movie,
but they're supposed to visit the main
X-Men universe,
one of the original movies
at some point too,
because that is the original universe
that Deadpool is from.
it's the same universe
from the first class movies
and at least the original Fantastic
Four movies in the Ben Affleck
Daredevil movie, the electro movie two.
I don't think the newer 2015 Fantastic
Four movie was in that universe,
but that's part of the joke of Deadpool.
Like Fox never really cared much
about their continuity in movies
with the reboots
only loosely trying to explain it.
That's
why Deadpool joked about it so much.
The theory is right now
they're paying off the A38 Universe story
in the ending of Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness, So it's possible
that a lot of the X-Men that are coming
back in the movie are the more comic book
versions from that universe.
So it makes sense if they're going
to visit that universe again.
And we see some of the other X-Men
coming back, baby wearing more colorful
comic book based uniforms, too.
In that universe.
but the entire movie
might not take place in the 838 universe
just because Deadpool is hopping around
with cable's time travel device,
which they also confirm that cable
is not coming back for them to be.
Josh Brolin's cable
will not be in the movie, but his time
travel device will be a big part
of how the movie plays out.
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references
in any of the footage in the video,
just write it below in the comments.
We'll get more teasers and trailers
later this year and we get a soak episodes
in a couple of weeks.
So be sure to enable all my channels
so you don't miss any of that stuff.
Click here for my full Loki Season
two trailer video and click here for that
brand new Ahsoka trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
Maximum effort!